next on encore book notes david remnick
author of lenin's tomb the last days of
the soviet empire it's an hour
david remnick of the new yorker why is
lenin still in his tomb in red square
well i think he's still in his tomb
because they want to avoid a political
war you remember at the end of uh as the
soviet union was falling apart there
were more and more calls saying look you
know we have this very grotesque symbol
of the country we have lennon still in
his tomb it's time to give him a decent
burial and we thought that this would
happen and yeltsin gave his sort of
half-hearted support but you you see now
that the communists such as they are
would would raise bloody murder about
this and there's really no political
percentage for the moment
in taking
the
the founder of the bolshevik state and
putting him in in the grave where really
he'll probably end up being after a few
years but there are many more important
political wars to to win and at the
moment the constitution is the first one
is that really him
well he has the consistency of the kind
of did you build you know models when
you're a kid of of of airplanes he has
that kind of plastic waxy look but uh
it's been quite a while it's been since
1923 or four i forget what it is at some
point you refer to um
a gymnasium underneath yeah
it's quite incredible
this is the holy of holies in in in
bolshevik mythology lenin's tomb
and um
but as the mystery around the soviet
regime began to dissipate and disappear
and there was more good journalism about
what it actually looked like and that
there are tunnels underneath the kremlin
leading to the kgb in a special subway
system in moscow that was just for
stalin's youth use to get out of town
fast they also discovered
that first of all the right now the
ministry controlling
lenin himself so that he doesn't
completely disintegrate into to
nothingness
is the uh russian institute for aromatic
plants and herbs
and that underneath the floor where
lenin is kept there's a
control room that looks like sort of a
nasa
space lab where they keep very careful
temperature control and all the rest
and also there's a gymnasium for where
the guards can go and work out i've
never seen the weights myself but
apparently it's quite a fully equipped
gym and there's a men's room for the for
the politburo which was mostly men uh if
they wanted to stop in and use the
facilities before the before or after
the mayday parade and a couple of
refrigerators for food and potables uh
it's
that kind of takes away the mystery when
you start to hear about that what years
were you in the soviet union well i i
went as a traveler before this but i
finally arrived as a reporter for the
washington post january 88
just as things were starting to
percolate in a significant way gorbachev
had already been in for two and a half
years but
this was really significant getting
glossness was starting to cook and i
left after the coup
and went back again in december
91 to to see the final collapse of the
soviet union why'd you call your book
lenin's tomb
well i think lenin's tomb is a kind of
ironic image
an image of
the death of of leninism of bolshevism i
think that'll never return
and also
for some of the things we were talking
about before a kind of ironic look at a
mysterious regime that is now laid bare
when you were there you tried to find
the oldest living i don't know what
you'd call it hatchet man for stalin
henchmen sure henchman or whatever there
was really only one left alive
uh of all of stalin's circle uh he had
either slaughtered them himself one by
one or they had died off after all was
many years since stalin's death he died
in 1953
and the one left alive was a man named
lazar kaganovich
and i was determined to go interview him
uh and i was looking for him and looking
for him and one fine day i was
in one of those apartment buildings
along the river that are kind of nice by
my moscow standards and i was
interviewing friends of mine uh flora
and misha litvinov in fact misha's
father had been maxime lavinov
the foreign commissar under stalin who
had barely escaped execution himself and
happily died in his bed a natural death
and i said you know i'm looking for
kaganovich
look i'm obsessed with this search and
he said well kaganovich she lives
you know six or seven floors underneath
us uh why don't you just go knock on his
door
so for months thereafter i knocked on
his door i slipped notes underneath the
door and occasionally i'd hear the shoe
shoop of uh
padded uh slippers uh going along a kind
of dusty floor but he never answered the
the door he was too smart for that and
uh two maybe two old uh but i discovered
these very odd little tidbits about him
that he was the domino's champion
of uh the neighborhood that he had that
he had demanded from the brezhnev
government that lights it would be
strung up in the
in the courtyard so he could play
dominoes at night so the old man still
had a little power left in him
and finally he died about
two months short of the soviet regime he
died in july of 91
at the age of 97 and i went to the
funeral saw him laid out
and
one of the liberal writers that i knew
in moscow adamowicz also went to the
funeral and he said you know this is a
lot like going to the funeral of nero
or himmler or somebody like that and he
said what could possibly be next
kaganovich is dead what could die next
the communist party and he said this in
a disbelieving way and two months later
the communist party was dead
tell us the difference between lenin and
stalin
well uh
in the i think the
main difference is the number of corpses
left behind
that
lenin was a different kind of man
admittedly more intellectual but i think
bloodthirsty in his own way we should we
kind of gave lennon a free ride
in some western histories of the soviet
regime saying that he was kind of
an intellectual who had to in order to
make an omelet had to break some eggs
but he had this wonderful revolution and
so on being extremely simplistic in this
but
but there were there was thinking that
if lenin had only lived beyond the early
20s that he would have liberalized the
regime
and you would have had socialism in our
time i think that's hoke hokum
bunk
and had he lived longer i think there
would be many many
corpses still to come
stalin was a
a brutal czar
uh on the order of yvonne the terrible
and in many ways as robert tucker's
biography showed his model for his
behavior his comportment and what he
wanted for russia was modeled more on
the most brutal of the czars than it was
on lenin himself that his commitment to
socialism as we understand that
academically was nil he wanted to be
the the viliki vost the great the great
tough leader who was required by russian
history all along speak russian i do
how many men did stalin kill or men and
women it you know it's a figure uh
that is is under dispute and
uh
solzhenitsyn for example has come up
with the figure 60 million based on
the the collectivization of the
countryside in which they were forced
starvation and executions the great
purges
the civil war it's it's very hard to
know uh where to draw the line but we
can safely say it's in the tens of
millions had to kill them
you know uh his technology wasn't as as
fine as hitler's there were no gas
chambers that we know of there were two
main ways of dying under stalin one was
to be shot in the back of the head
by an executioner wearing a long
raincoat and rubber gloves
very often you'd be shot by being put
into a room with a little door and the
door would open and the hand would come
out and you'd be shot in the back of the
head
in fact in in lenin's tomb there's a
long account given by a man who saw
these executions
near the polish border
of polish officers yet an another large
group of stalin's victims the other way
to die and most likely the way my wife's
grandfather died for example in the
camps was just to be worked to death
because after all the slave labor camps
was free cheap
labor for the soviet regime to
to mine gold in
the soviet far east or to build
steel mills or whatever
and they would just work you to death
until you died of consumption
your family
your wife is a journalist she is she
is now on uh maternity leave we just had
a child a couple of weeks ago
now too
and uh
she's with the new york times esther
fine and she writes about publishing
when she was in moscow obviously she
wrote about the same thing so we were
rivals in crime in a way washington post
new york times it was kind of an odd
arrangement where did you live
we lived at the time the only place you
could live which were these state
rendered apartments and they were fairly
grim but they were far more comfortable
than any than than most muscovites were
were accustomed to very ordinary
one-bedroom apartment kind of spartan
uh
fairly near the office 10 minutes away
nothing special if you had to go back to
the to russia or any place in the soviet
union the old soviet union today if you
had to pick one character that you knew
who would you who would you pick who
would you go
seek out to seek out well i think
although i think the world may be tiring
of him
i think that gorbachev is still
of the living characters they're still
the most endlessly fascinating because
he is shakespearean in his
attempt to do something great
and
it became something else
and his inability to react to that
something else was tragic
maybe i should explain that
he wanted to liberalize communism he
wanted the regime and the soviet union
to modernize to
to
get in get into the wave of modern
technology for example and to do that he
knew he had to open the system at least
a bit
so that you could accommodate computers
which they really didn't have or even
xerox machines or
an understanding of history that
accorded with the world um
he needed to romance the intellectuals
and he wanted to end the cold war
because the cold war after all cost a
fortune
he wanted to do all these things and in
many ways he did them but it led to
another chain of events it led to a
logic of events
the the birth of nationalism
the birth of the desire for free speech
as opposed to just limited gloss nosed
all these things
happen in such a rush and such a
cacophony
at a time when he was surrounded by the
kgb and the military and and forces that
didn't want this in any way they didn't
want to see this liberalization
and he had to do a political juggling
act that finally went awry of course in
the coup
you went uh back to where he was born i
did i had a bit of a time of it too look
for old girlfriend
i went to
uh southern russia gorbachev is from
southern russia and he has in fact a
southern accent
uh he's a peasant boy
and he was born in a place called
privolneo which means free and easy
and his father was the head of the
collective farm and he won an award for
harvesting and he was kind of uh the
eagle scout of his town and he was a
good
uh comsomo boy in school and kind of a
class president type a bit a bit um
sanctimonious in his behavior uh a bit
bossy and he was there's this picture
from by the way that is a picture of the
school play that he was in and he is in
uh i guess that's from masquerade which
is a lairmantov play and he's and he's
there with his his girlfriend who's the
leading lady it's a kind of a touching
thing when you went back to the village
uh were they glad to see you
well anything but anything did you go
there i went 89 just as right before the
summit malta
and um
i went south and i went to stavropol
which is the regional capital an
agricultural center beautiful good
weather anything very unlike northern
russia where it's hard to grow things
uh
got a sense of of his geography of his
topography the kind of rich soil
an easier lifestyle you could see the
kind of roots of his optimism a little
bit things grew ease more easily there
and i went around and saw people that he
knew as a as a young man and as even as
a child
but provolna itself which is a tiny
village
extremely rural maybe i don't even
remember how many people are there now
maybe less than a hundred just some
chickens some some some peasant huts and
a small schoolhouse
but there was also a kgb guard house
there looking over
maria pontileva his his mother they
didn't want any reporters knocking on
the door american style you know like
going to see mrs clinton uh
or
or bill clinton's mother
as as is the style here they don't want
any of that and they certainly didn't
want it in 1989
and so
they told me that there was hoof and
mouth disease in the village and i
couldn't go
and i knew this was ridiculous and i
woke up at 4 35 o'clock in the morning
it was still dark out
and there are no cabs to speak of on the
street at five o'clock much less at 4 30
in the morning
and so i just hailed the nearest car and
i gave him some
hard currency twenty dollars for the day
which is an enormous sum at that time
and first we went to a village called
krasnodkuvardyesk
red guard which is the place where
gorbachev went to high school and he
would make the long walk from privoline
to krasnook of our disc every week
with his satchel and his friends and
he'd stay in a kind of a rooming house
and i met a lot of people there and it i
got to meet a lot of people but after
five hours the local authorities caught
up with me and on the way back and on
the way there i got a glimpse of
provolnae as well but it was much harder
to do much work there how did mr
gorbachev treat his mother
well she she apparently he always wanted
her to move to moscow which is in the
style of prolifera members and she
refused and her hut is fairly ordinary
although she's
considered fairly wealthy for having a
nice big colored television and
it's slightly cleaner than the other uh
huts and she obviously gets protection
that the others don't and once i
remember on his birthday there was a in
his attempt to recapture some popularity
which was fast fading as you remember in
the soviet union they had a kind of you
know andy williams christmas special
sort of thing where this is your life
michelle gorbachev and they interviewed
him at great length uh and heard great
length and she talked about how he
played the bella like
it was kind of a parody of western
network television i'm afraid and it was
rather pathetic and had the opposite
effect people laughed at it there's a
lot we can talk about with him and we'll
come back but uh if you did go back
there right now and
seek him out what would you find him
doing
hustling i'm afraid that he is extremely
money conscious and maybe even more so
extremely reputation conscious
he spends a lot of time touring the
world
and speaking for large fees he was
recently a couple of months ago i think
in virginia
uh and he university
yeah and he was but he was everywhere he
unbeknownst to the various uh uh
sponsors there he had booked himself at
every dinner in the state of virginia
for for about a week and uh it's at the
level almost of embarrassment he came to
the united states remember a year or two
ago
flying in the forbes plane the
capitalist tool and he saw no irony in
this it's it's a very odd thing for
somebody who's seemingly so self-aware
i don't think he's doing himself any
favors in the reputation department he's
also writing his memoir and finally it
seems he's going to do a serious memoir
because his other books are really quite
awful
you say that um
the bbc's paying him 600
000 pounds i i forget the figure it's in
it's in the book but it's quite a lot of
money and by by moscow standards 600 000
pounds will
buy a lot of bellini's and
much less plots of land
and apparently he's giving them lots of
papers and access to his friends and
making things easy for them to do a
tv documentary is there any comparison
at all between mr gorbachev and an
american politician
well
in spots yes i've i don't think i've
seen a uh i'm 34 and so my memories of
lyndon johnson are are
somewhat vague but to watch him rule
over a congress of people's deputies at
his the height of his powers 88.89
it puts you in mind of you know lyndon
johnson in the senate or sam rayburn or
somebody like that he had that kind of
wheeling and dealing and ultimate power
of the institution of course he had an
advantage
he was the tsar
and you listen to him even more acutely
than a house of representatives member
would listen to sam rayburn
so at that on that level uh he had that
kind of power he but he also
he remember he was the first real tv
politician
in in russia and he could but he
controlled the tv he would call the
studio i mean you can imagine the
strangeness of you know somebody in the
senate calling brian lamb and saying
look i want to be shown in a certain way
on c-span cut out that shot where i kind
of was scratching my ear that that's no
good and when i made that grammatical
flub you know get rid of that too and
try to get the secret servicemen out of
the picture so it looks more natural
like but that's what he did and he had
propagandists around him doing this they
were very tv conscious this was the
first time
that they were so self-aware in fact tv
was the real enemy of the regime until
gorbachev
when brezhnev would go on television he
would he could hardly speak he was so
old and infirm
and people would laugh at him he spoke
he they said he talks like a crocodile
his mouth would flap open and shut it
was rather sad
and that became the symbol of the
decay of uh the soviet of soviet power
it's way off the subject but maybe you
can help us better understand we carry
channel one's evening news show uh from
us duncan
every
five days a week here
um what are we getting now i mean you
write about how that was so controlled
is the yeltsin administration
controlling i think
you know although i've been called a
great supporter of yeltsin and i think
that's slightly unfair i think that
yeltsin has too much control over state
television it is state television by the
way but you also have state television
in much of western europe so
i think for example when there was the
great conflict a few months ago between
yeltsin and his conservative rivals in
the in the congress
that as much as i wanted to see yeltsin
win that conflict that the conservatives
had a point
when they said that look yeltsin's
really controlling these newscasts they
were extremely in an unsophisticated way
uh propagandistic not maybe like it was
10 years ago under the communist regime
but in a way that still makes me
uncomfortable this is the tiny little
footnote question you you write um you
know in the back of your notes on
sources which you tell us how you got
some of the information for the
different chapters i just wanted to
quote back to you this raise raisa
gorbachev's memoir i hope
is sentimental and almost entirely
useless
i i wondered why you uh see anyone else
but it contains some interesting letters
and other glances at life in stavropol
and in the kremlin
well i'm afraid that it's a very bad
book and i and i sort of feel that i owe
it uh when discussing if i'm going to
make the point that there's no good
biographies of him and i'm
having at least a short analysis of the
extant literature on gorbachev i should
give an opinion or two
about what's out there and raises book
is kind of a
i don't know you see them here these
kind of
supermarket package
quickie biographies and she did one
where she allowed herself to be
interviewed extensively
and it was you know a trifle but there
are letters in there that i find very
interesting
if they're authentic and i assume they
are gorbachev writing to raisa when they
were quite young
gorbachev expressing his extreme
frustration with the local authorities
how how hidebound they were how
conservative how they say things they
don't mean how mechanical they are and
it showed a certain germ of frustration
but we should also never forget what a
good
player in public gorbachev was he after
all became general secretary of the
communist party and you don't do that by
being a rebel you also talk in that same
section about an american journalist
gail sheehy's biography quoting you
contains some interesting information
from our own trips to the stavropol
region but the book is too weighted down
by inaccuracies and misunderstandings of
soviet history and politics well uh i
just feel that it's not a very good book
and it because if it was a book that got
no attention
and just sort of fell by the wayside i
wouldn't feel compelled to comment on it
at all
but if it's something that it has a
place in the literature at least the
contemporary literature
i i feel compelled to say that it's it's
just
it's not very good and when when
when a biographer begins talking about
how the spot on gorbachev's head changes
color with his moods or begins
overrating terribly the influence of his
wife on the history of perestroika i
think that that's just absurd and and at
least a short comment is due i thought
the real the the good review done on
that was by tatiana talstaya
in the new republic at the time and
really was quite tough to say the least
and
really jumped on her for any number of
inaccuracies it's something i i hope
doesn't happen to me but um
but if i'm filled with inaccuracies it
should uh on the flap your book
lenin's tomb is full of arresting
anecdotes lively characters and a
panorama view of the soviet union in its
last years under gorbachev norman mailer
that your idea is it my idea no but i
and i don't know norman miller i should
i hasten to add i always wonder where
these things come from it's right away
robert carro is on the back you know
i i've i've met him for five ten minutes
and i interviewed him once i was in your
chair to to
interviewing him long ago for texas
monthly but in a very kind of impersonal
way and
but he is somebody and mailer as well
that i admire tremendously and i'm very
flattered to
have their
billboard 550 pages how did you go about
what do people get in this book
well what i hope they get
is a kind of
sense of what was important what and the
book begins with the first
quarter of the book is about the opening
up of history
uh many people feel that gorbachev's
primary
project in the beginning in the year in
the mid 80s was to improve the economy
and that's true enough but he was dismal
failure at it as we see to this day what
i think was the key moment was when he
got up in november 1987 and he said and
he was the anniversary of the revolution
and he said and all the assembled
communists were there even from other
countries and they were very nervous
about what he was going to say about the
history of the revolution because after
all the legitimacy of their regimes
depended on the stability of the soviet
regime castro as an example all of
eastern europe
and he got up and he gave what we now
see is a very mild speech
an outdated speech but for the time
extremely important he said comrades
uh of course things are going splendidly
of course the revolution is glorious and
we should never spit on it
but
there were moments in our history that
were were awful
and
he used the word criminal to describe
the regime of stalin this was an
incredible breakthrough now khrushchev
had done something similar what year was
that what was your year was the
gorbachev speech 1987 and 30 years
before khrushchev had done something
similar in what we now call the thaw but
he had done it in secret
the so-called secret speech to the 20th
party congress this was on national
television it was it was being watched
very carefully
and he said that these
crimes of the stolen era uh were
criminal
and that people who had been executed
were uh didn't deserve it buharin was
one of them nikolai bucharan who was one
of the original bolsheviks a a
follower of lenin and someone considered
slightly
uh certainly more liberal uh or or less
draconian than than stalin
this was wrong he didn't speak very
highly of trotsky and there's no reason
he should have actually
but this was a a crack a fisher in the
in the monolith
and it it was the communist party
attempting to redefine history to bring
up some new heroes the new heroes were
khrushchev as a reforming czar which is
what gorbachev wanted to be bucharen who
presented an alternative to stalin the
road not taken
and to some degree even andropov who
after all was uh gorbachev's political
mentor andropov had been general
secretary two people before him
this was a crucial moment and what
happened in the ensuing year year and a
half
was that everybody took this as a cue to
really examine history now why is this
important
it's not just an academic thing
for example in the baltic states it
opened the discussion about the
molotov-ribbentrop pact which was the
document the event that that captured in
a sense the three baltic states
and it had always been considered uh uh
official soviet history that the baltic
states had voluntarily joined the soviet
union well it was that was complete
nonsense that we put the lie to that
with an examination of history this
began the baltic independence movement
in a serious way
or the relationship with eastern europe
began to we began to look at that much
more carefully in the soviet press
and books that were now being published
this was absolutely crucial to me it
really opened the pandora's box and
began
uh the revolt that ended the way we see
it and having ended you also have in
here a an account a rather extensive
account a hundred pages worth
i believe of the um the whole coup
attempt yeah
uh is there anything new in there yeah
and in fact there's a lot new uh to be
honest um
by the way when did you write that i i
wrote it and continued revising it up
until this past march in april
because of the wonders of modern
publishing you can now still monkey with
things uh and and one of the
the boons for me
uh was
uh
there was a prosecutor's report
prosecutors on the for the russians went
and interviewed everybody that had
organized and taken part in the coup and
they amassed hundreds of volumes we
don't have access to that but the
prosecutors amazingly god knows what
they were thinking they published
commercially before any trial
an account of what these people had said
on the most important issues who said
what to whom
and it's only been published in russian
and i was able to get a copy of this
while preparing this chapter and so i
have dialogue
within the kremlin on you know sort of
forcing people to sign this document and
this one being drunk and that one having
to be carried out of the kremlin because
he was so smashed
or the other one being sick i mean it
was it was
as jim hoagland wrote at the time of the
washington post he said it was the coup
had begun
like dostoyevsky and it ended like the
marx brothers and it really was when you
think about the coup an
incredibly historic
uh moment because it was the was its
failure was what finally collapsed the
regime
but the way it was carried out was
if you saw duck soup tomorrow it would
look rather similar to the soviet coup
uh appears that a lot of drinking going
on around the coup especially for a
couple of them uh and in fact the the
the titular leader of the coup gennady
anaya who was the vice president at the
time was was just
stone drunk
why did he ever go on television with
that group shake his hand i mean we all
remember seeing his hand shaking his
hand was flooded against a cigarette oh
god he was saying why did they do that
why did he do because they had to
they had to what were they left with
after all
they had to go in front of the people
unless they were willing to go back to
stalinist times and kill everybody that
objected
and that option quickly ran out they had
to lie
they had to use the old methods of
propaganda
and so the assembled leadership comes
and comes into the foreign ministry
press center i forget how many there
were not all of them were there but
yanayev and khrushchev and
all the cast of characters
and they had to get up and say well our
friend michelle gorbachev is temporarily
indisposed in pharos which is in
his vacation home in the south
and of course we will continue with
reforms but after all comrades things
have gotten out of hand it's unstable
the country is falling apart we need to
have emergency rule for a while
we're going to take care of it and when
that's taken care of gorbachev will come
back up he has his frequent flyer miles
he'll fly up and and uh and that'll be
the end of it and everything will be
back to normal of course it was nonsense
and all you needed to know
was to look to to know that it was
nonsense was to see gennady in naive's
hand shaking like a leaf out of sheer
nervousness
because he had to do a preposterous task
you've got a couple of pictures here and
this was a gentleman this this is you
i'm afraid who's the man that you're
standing next to that's igor ligachow
who was gorbachev's uh ally in the
beginning of perestroika but within a
couple of years became
his main conservative uh foe where was
he during the coup
he was on vacation he really so far as
we know had little or nothing to do with
the coup i think he probably in fact
he's told me he supported the aims
of the coup in terms of stabilization
but he was out of harm's way but then he
was retired gorbachev had finally pushed
him aside where is he now
he's on book tour so far as i know brian
i think he's written a very good memoir
filled with
uh fables and lies but very good in that
it gives an inside look at the
opposition within the kremlin during
perestroika
and it's called inside gorbachev's
kremlin i believe uh
called the enigma of gorbachev in
russian
and uh
and it's filled with interesting stories
some of them may be true how many of the
coup
plotters are still in jail
they're not in jail anymore in fact
they've come up for trial
and the trial's been put off and put off
and
uh i think it's something that
even the yeltsin government would like
to sort of suspend indefinitely because
it's in nobody's interest politically
except justice's interest
to have this trial going on it's very
embarrassing where are they then they're
at home
i went and interviewed gennady and if
last time i was in moscow
which was just a couple of few months
ago i went and saw gennady and nayev and
the only reason i saw univ and not all
the others is because the others were
charging a lot of money to to be
interviewed they've all gotten a bit of
hollywood in them it's it's incredible
who pays their bills every month besides
the this kind of
fee stuff they they get these fees here
and there and um
and they have their big apartments left
over from their time in government it's
pretty cheap to live even if you have
just a little bit of hard currency some
of them write books
you point out that if
that the former communist apparatus or
the bureaucrats were pulled back into
the government and they're still there
now because they're competent this is
the great dilemma
in this in the former soviet union and
throughout the communist world
yes a lot of them are morally tainted
yes they did business with some very bad
people or that were themselves very bad
people during the regime
but after all who knows how to run a
steel plant who knows how to run a shoe
factory however badly
and
you've got to do this to get along and
you can't just pluck people right out of
college and say run the steel plant so
as with politicians
i think it's going to be a long
transition before you see these 25 year
olds become 40 year old managers and and
politicians
where were you born i was born in jersey
new jersey where hillsdale new jersey
what was the family like
fairly ordinary family father uh now a
retired dentist uh
mother housewife and uh
and there thank god still around and uh
very excited that the book is out
where is your family from originally
well uh all of it from from
russia russian jews so i can't i can't
call them russians um
and my grandfathers both uh escaped or
got out of russia
or or ukraine uh
before the revolution and when i took
the 1917 revolution yes and before i
left uh the one who was still alive uh
he was 102 at the time and i went to
visit him in florida and i said you know
grandpa i'm going to go move to moscow
and he looked at me like i would i was
absolutely crazy his worst nightmare had
occurred his his his precious grandchild
was going to go back into the into the
land that he had escaped from uh so it
all seemed very weird to them what about
your wife esther fine well that is even
more dramatic uh esther's grandfather um
well
their whole that whole side of the
family were in can
had been in camps
esther's grandfather
died or was killed in camp
the grandmother and esther's mother and
aunt and uncle got out
they were in camps though they were in
children's detention camps
and happily survived them and made their
way west across europe and and left
you read a lot about being jewish and
being jewish and living in the soviet
union being jewish and being a soviet
citizen or russian citizen
what's the genesis of the hatred
this is a very large question where does
anti-semitism come from i i i it's a
it's extremely complicated uh and i i
would say this though
that one of the
best outcomes uh of this whole process
in the last
six seven years
is that anti-semitism contrary to a lot
of scare journalism on the rise of the
right wing and fascism neo-fascism is
that anti that anti-semitism is on the
fade part of it is that so many jews
left on the fade there yes and uh this
is borne out in arthur hertzberg's piece
of the new york review about
the the easing of anti-semitism uh
thankfully in ukraine and russia
uh on the other hand there are new
groups to hate
that if if the jews were hate group
number one ten years ago it's they've
now sort of descended on this dubious
ladder and atop at the top of the ladder
or armenians azerbaijanis georgians
central asians because they're so much
more present
and there's just as turks are in in
germany they're the kind of gostar
barger the guest workers who are in the
midst of a very
humiliated uh people the russians was
this your first book it is
is it what you thought it would be
you know uh
very much so um i
had read a lot of the journalists books
uh about russia before i left and i am
an admirer of many of them
uh
but they seemed some of them seem to
have a certain quality of kind of john
gunther
type books in other words they were the
book about everything about russian
society education the economy sports
medicine and i didn't want to repeat
that performance so i wanted to tell
more of a narrative story
and uh
you know the revolution certainly
provided a hell of a narrative and my
job was to find some shape to it go back
to your new jersey upbringing
you remember when you first got
interested in writing
yeah uh
very early on in junior high school and
uh i was
in in in high school where nobody had an
interest in making a
a school newspaper i was doing basically
the whole thing at my bridge table at
home staying up till two o'clock in the
morning
where did you get that interest i i
don't know but from reading
being not only a newspaper junkie but
also interested in in in books more
serious than that who got you interested
in that uh my parents are readers my
father uh is
uh is a very serious reader my mother to
some extent and
it's like anything in life if you're
lucky enough to hook into a friend
and find something to share
it's very exciting it doesn't seem like
homework and i went to a pretty good
high school but they didn't assign books
in any serious way unfortunately but i
had a friend and we would go to use book
sales and trade books and
but things russian
i was really always interested in but
not through russian politics because
when i was growing up russian politics
were a boar
it was a kind of
solid
ideological
off theirness that i wanted nothing to
do with i was interested because chekhov
was so interesting and does they ask in
tolstoy it sounds pretentious to say
but there it is where'd you go to
college i went to princeton why
because i got in
and at princeton i was a disastrous
russian student because i had some
russian in hit in high school i had
insisted on you know advancing a little
bit and that was a fatal mistake and uh
so my russian was no good when i left uh
princeton your language or your
understanding of russia well my russian
language was just no good i i sort of
blew it in college and then finally
dropped it but afterwards uh
uh and when i found out i'd be going to
moscow especially we really intensified
russian language
study
uh studied with a woman here in in in
washington but the the real breakthrough
was at middlebury college in vermont
which has a remarkable
uh language program and my wife who
started from nothing and i who started
from just slightly more
after
after a while were getting pretty good
and certainly in moscow we got a lot
better where'd you meet your wife i met
her here in washington uh on a kind of
semi
uh blind day and uh and when faced with
going to moscow we kind of gave them a
twin announcement
the good news is we're getting married
and the bad news is we're going to
moscow and what was she doing then she
was at the new york times and you were
at the post yeah did you come right out
of princeton and go to the post
strangely enough yes how'd you get to do
that
blind luck i i was an intern a couple of
times at the washington post and
somebody who's now the editor of the la
times shelby coffee uh
said you know come back but the star has
just folded so get lost for a year
and i went and taught in japan and
traveled around india and got lost for a
year and came back and started and did
night police and sports i was a sports
reporter in washington for a couple of
years and
i think i think i may have set the
record for being in more sections than
anybody in the history of the washington
post
someplace back there and i remember this
popped up during the campaign in 1992
uh you became the object of ross perot
uh or you know i i guess what i remember
is you wrote a wrote a piece on the
op-ed page of the western post
about an experience you had with ross
perot and then that became an issue
later on what was that story well i
think it was an issue that or an
incident that became rather indicative
of his behavior
uh rather odd behavior um
long before we had heard that he was
going to run for president i did a
two-part magazine
story on ross perot for the washington
post magazine how long ago was this
gibran i'm not really sure the year but
it was maybe 85
86 whenever the magazine sort of changed
itself i forget the year at the moment
maybe even 86.87 i forget
and uh i was interviewing him had
several interviews with him in dallas
and his family took me all over the
state and texarkana these the days when
this was still possible it was the usual
seduction process writ large by ross
perot
and the subject
jumped to
his interest in vietnam
pows
and
his real whipping boy at that point was
a man named armitage
uh
who richard richard armitage who was if
i recall correctly was in charge of pow
affairs for the reagan
administration pentagon yeah and and
perrault did not like him thought he was
a
dishonest
cover-up artist or whatever it was and i
i don't want to try to quote him exactly
from memory but then he went into perot
got up in his kind of funny way went
into his safe which is
quite large as you can imagine he has a
lot to save
and he came out with
some photographs of armitage seated with
a vietnamese woman who apparently is
was of unsavory reputation for one
reason or another
and then be
to me began to impute all things about
all manner of things about armitage
again i i want to keep this story as
vague as possible because i'd have to
review my notes to get it exact but
as we saw in the campaign this kind of
behavior was not uh unusual
that kind of
um sense of paranoia
that that willingness to attack like
that uh became rather commonplace in
fact he claims to have dropped out of
the campaign because of an attack on him
and his daughter and the whole wedding
scene you remember that all too well
so that's what it was and i i just
decided you know that wasn't even in my
magazine piece because i was at that
point
writing about
an extremely rich slightly eccentric
businessman and as i look back on those
pieces they weren't terribly tough
and
but when you run for president it's a
different matter and he's a serious
candidate
and i thought i needed to put what i
knew out there not as out of any self
self-aggrandizement i was on leave from
the post but i just thought it was
important but then you did come back
though and write a piece
last year
for what reason in the post about all
this
no i wrote a piece during the campaign
for the washington post op-ed sex that's
what i mean i mean yeah but that was the
first time you'd ever written about it
about that incident about that answer
yeah it just uh to be honest brian it
didn't fit in
to the magazine stories
it just was such an odd little incident
that i
it some sometimes things go out of your
mind or off the off the off the radar
screen and they don't make any kind of
personal or dramatic or journalistic
sense until a context appears and a
context was beginning to appear during
the presidential race did you hear him
after you wrote that no but you know he
would go on tv and say it was false and
it wasn't false it was absolutely true
you spent how many years with the
washington post ten when did you leave
i left and and with with uh with great
regret um in 1992 essentially i came
back from from moscow at the end of 91
they i gave me a leave and i went off
and wrote this book at the council on
foreign relations
and another opportunity came up and for
reasons personal and in terms of what i
wanted to do with my life i stayed in
new york and joined the new yorker
why did you use the council on foreign
relations as a place to write this i got
a grant i was the uh edward r murrow uh
fellow at the council which provided
some money and a
small room in which to work it was
paradise now how often do they do that
they have one a year
and in fact i think one of my colleagues
from uh
moscow is going to be the in the coming
year woman from uh business week any
strings attached when you take that
grant uh no
it's
it's really remarkable and uh
and some books of other journalists have
used it to write their books and others
have used it just to to study and or to
open up some new
vista for themselves in terms of
language or or area studies what are you
doing now
right now i'm writing
uh various pieces for the new yorker
thinking about uh the next book i have a
piece out in the new yorker on luciano
pavarotti on opera and i've written
about gary hart recently for the for the
new yorker and moscow as well so i've
been kind of a free-range chicken these
days do you have uh a certain beat or
they let you do anything you want to do
uh
paradise again has found its way and
it's it's pretty much well
anything i want to do with the tina
brown say so and why did you pick the
new yorker
well i picked the new yorker because
that's where i that is
i was raised to think that that was
where nirvana was
that's where
i more than a newspaper reporter a daily
newspaper reporter i fancied myself a
writer of longer things
not better just different and
happily at the washington post they had
room and gave found room for longer
things in the style section and even
foreign it's very innovative foreign
editor there michael getler who really
does like to open up the section quite a
bit
but in the end events a daily newspaper
is a daily newspaper and to sort of buck
that is is folly
and the new yorker is where new yorker
pieces should be not the washington post
live in new york city downtown manhattan
right in the right in the right in the
hall what's your wife doing now well on
leave but she she's a new york times
reporter and uh writes about publishing
and
writers not me
let's go back to the book lennon's tomb
which uh we'll show the audience what it
looks like and i got a picture i want to
ask you about inside it's the one down
here that's boris yeltsin you uh
referred earlier to uh a lot of people
think you're pro yeltsin and that there
was a review in uh of lenin's tomb in
which he uh the reviewer said uh remnick
seems to really be uh even i think the
phrase was in love with or a great
admirer of yeltsin well
if there was any public figure that i
loved while in moscow it was sahrof
um
somebody a far
greater man than
any i've had the privilege to be in
proximity to yeltsin is a great
politician a great confrontation
politician
uh and history for once found the right
order for the figures it required
gorbachev came at the right time he was
a liberalizer a continuer of the
khrushchev tradition of opening the
system
bit by bit
yeltsin was a great destroyer in a way
he came along and he through kind of his
impudence helped smash the monolith of
the communist party remember when he had
that great outburst and he was fired
from the politburo that helped open up
the communist party even more and then
he comes along
and finds his political niche in the
republic of russia
and he finds himself a power base there
and he is there at the right moment to
stand up to the coup
uh
gorbachev was more of a juggler
somebody who would kind of temporize uh
try to find compromises eternally and
that was very important but
in the moments when yeltsin was there
yeltsin uh was the right person you
mentioned that was a picture of soccer
off on that sign um
you mentioned that uh when sakuraoff
came
back to moscow after living in gorky
when he was free well he was he was he
didn't just live there he was put there
by the government who wanted him out of
sight out of mind for a number of
reasons but specifically his opposition
to the afghan war but when he did come
back you say he didn't give many
interviews well he wasn't quite as
available as he had been when you if you
were a moscow reporter in the 70s
you spent a lot of time if you were any
good at andre sakharov's kitchen table
just
shooting the breeze and finding out
what's going on in the dissidents
movement and
his kitchen table was to some extent the
center
of dissidents in the soviet union
but when he returned he became uh
especially after his election to the
congress of people's deputies
one
a the moral leader certainly of the
democratic opposition but a tired man
and one who needed to spare himself uh
endless interviews with a with a growing
press course so his kitchen was a little
bit more sacred territory than it had
been oh i've been there and talked to
him there but it wasn't the same
frequency you also mentioned quite often
uh subject subject uh was probably a
politician that we westerners took a
liking to faster than russians
themselves sub chuck is the mayor of den
leningrad now st petersburg kind of
handsome a little bit proud of his own
oratory
uh
quite smart
but he doesn't have that quality that
yeltsin has which is of being a music a
guy who a guy you could imagine knocking
back a few vodkas with subchak is a
little too academic to get that kind of
broad-based support
i just want to show a couple photos and
just talk about these folks len
karpenski len karpinski
is somebody who described him he
described himself as a half dissident
he was a man of the gorbachev generation
who
was blessed by the communist party his
father was an old bolshevik who knew
lenin
he grew up in very privileged bolshevik
circumstances
he had gone rapidly up the ladder of the
young communist league and all the rest
but finally like many
semi-liberal
communist party operatics when it came
to the invasion of czechoslovakia in
1968 he said no more
and began
separating himself from the world of
officialdom and finally was fired from
pravda and his vestia comes the
moleskine problem
two photos
over here on this page where did they
come from and why are they in here well
those photos i really uh to me have
written on them
soviet history and the difficulty of
life there really etched in their faces
not to say that you wouldn't see faces
like that necessarily in
in west virginia or or anywhere in the
world but to me
uh the woman
both of these people are from siberia
and life is tough
in that part of the world and i just
could feel it see it in those faces and
a siberian photographer took those
photographs man named kuznetsov how
about this photo
well to me
this is the this is the
to me a symbol of the kind of
frustration of the
apparatchik the local official who's
worked under the portrait of lenin for
many years and it's all going to hell
it's all falling apart and his confusion
is really evident there i think
do you still see photos of
lennon around mostly in dumpsters i'm
afraid and and or in ironic uh
uh settings you see a lot of old
communist memorabilia being sold to
western tourists who come back and buy
it for a giggle
it's kind of sad
the whole thing at the end you uh you
you say and you say you wrote for the
new yorker and vanity fair uh
part of that is in the last chapter when
you talk about
uh
the
trial
right at one point i just want to ask
you about though is i i just had never
seen this before uh it's a small point
but when general ackermayoff committed
suicide yeah uh you say that he tried
once
and it didn't work and he wrote
the the
the rope broke and then he did it again
and he and he wrote a note and he said
even at this i'm failing generally i
should do a little background sure
general ahmed who was greatly admired in
some way by the military establishment
here in the united states especially
admiral crow if i remember correctly our
audience saw a lot of him because we
carried those hearings when he testified
sure and uh
but i think he was a little bit
romanticized in the united states he
really was a quite a hard-liner
and he was on vacation during the coup
he was not so far as we know in on the
planning of it
but when the coup began he rushed on his
own to moscow and did what he could
he was sort of there in the military
collegium and and making decisions on
what to do about raiding or not raiding
the the parliament as you remember
but the coup fell apart and he wrote a
note a very profound letter to gorbachev
saying you know i i uh
i felt i had to do this to save the
country
and the country is falling apart
everything i've worked for in my entire
life
is is going to hell it's falling apart
and he just
was defeated he was a defeated man who
would give given everything for his
country
and now it was being shattered and
people were calling it an illusion a
fraud and a brutal regime and he killed
himself
you have a photo you credit
reuters in the back here and this book's
called lenin's tomb and that is from
lenin's tomb
how often do they let photographs of
this i think quite rarely
lenin's tomb is quite controlled and
i should say the lines are a lot shorter
to go see him it used to be a required
stop for any soviet tourists coming from
tashkent or
ashrabad you would be required to go see
lennon's tomb and stand on a long line
but i i i don't think you can take a
picture very often it's quite a good one
actually how much longer will that name
be around lenin yeah and in that country
i mean will there ever be an attempt
just to
i think it'll be around forever because
his effect on
the landscape of russia and the states
that were part of the soviet union
is in many ways it's going to take a
long time to get rid of the ill effects
of that regime
it's in the souls of so many people is a
statue still there that the picture
you're showing there brian is a is a
statue of lenin in front of the uh the
would-be
magadan communist party headquarters in
the far east in fact margadon was the
center of the
labor camps in the far east
and as another
you know the symbolism came rather cheap
there
and the communist party decided they
didn't have the funds to build this new
plush
uh party headquarters and they abandoned
it after they had built the shell and
people used it for picnics and they
broke the windows and it was rather
pathetic
what's your next book
i wish i knew i wish i knew i'm so
casting around
what about the next trip to russia i
hope in the fall i hope to go a couple
times a year i'm very interested for
example and what's going on uh
how things are much the same in some
places and how far fast they've come in
others for example in estonia you see
almost a kind of
chicago school milton friedman
iron rand economics in place a kind of
crazy capitalism going on
and in turkmenistan nothing's changed in
fact the human rights violations are as
they were in some instances
and the authoritarian totalitarian grip
has not eased very much at all
we are out of time david remnick who is
the author of this book called lennon's
tomb the last days of the soviet empire
and we thank you very much for joining
us thank you brian
lennon's tomb the last days of the
soviet empire is published by random
house on the web at randomhouse.com